in just six days voters head to the
polls to decide who controls congress in
the critical midterm elections
this is president trump kicks off his
final campaign blitz in the key
state of florida where bernie sanders
will also be holding a dueling rally
the president confident about
republicans chances
on tuesday it seems that the campaign is
going very well looks like we're doing
very very well in the senate a lot of
seats that were not really being thought
of in terms of
victories a year ago now are looking
like they could very well be victories
and
the house is uh a lot of people i mean
there are a lot of people and
i think we're going to do well in the
house also but i know we're doing well
in the senate and i
it looks like we're doing okay in the
house trump also
issuing a new warning about what will
happen if democrats take the house
if the midterms for some reason don't do
so well for republicans
i think you're all going to lose a lot
of money i hate to say that i think
you're going to lose a lot of money
people are waiting on your 401ks and
everything else they're waiting
to see what happens with the midterms
meanwhile democrat nancy pelosi is
already taking a victory lap
predicting her party has the house in
the back
up until today i would have said if the
election were held today
we would win what happened today that
changed that
what now i'm saying is we will win
please don't say that do you want to say
that on on hillary's fireworks barge
that she canceled
please please please don't say that when
we own the ground we're not yielding
one grain of sand wow and yeah she
guaranteed victory the democrats did in
2016 too that's right didn't turn out so
well what do you think about pelosi's
prediction
judge i don't think much of pelosi i'll
start there
i mean look they they use hollywood
celebrities all the time
it didn't matter they were huge
celebrities hillary thought she was a
celebrity the president went out and
campaigned
for hillary and in the end it didn't
matter barbara streisand said she was
moving to canada
now she's threatening to move to canada
again they always say that they always
say that but in the end look the
republicans care about their money the
president is right
and i think though there's a little
trouble in the house well i mean it
sounded like the president wasn't as
confident in the house as he was in the
senate greg what do you make about
his tone there well first if streisand
moves to canada i hear canada is moving
to new zealand
because right now both here's what i'm
thinking both sides are doing the same
thing right now
they're riling up the base they're like
they're like motivational speakers
who tell you the worst possible scenario
don't do that to me so uh so like so if
trump wins the left says that
granny's gonna be pushed off a cliff
they're gonna take her social security
and we're gonna and the white men are
gonna put little boys in cages
right and then but if trump wins the
left says oh
uh all caravans are welcome and english
will be banned in
high school so it's like everybody's
doing
neither reality is actually true but
what they're doing is they're
they're creating a broad broadly based
assumption
based on the stereotype and that they're
both doing it so they're both guilty
it's true and trump's tactic
it could be a little more true than some
of the other
more scare tactics like greg mentioned
the economy one
i mean you just had 3.1 percent wage
growth this year highest in a decade
consumer confidence highest since 1980
98 and someone very smart on cavuto's
show just said this and i'm going to
take credit for it
they said in 1998 it was the last time
consumer confidence was this high and
bill clinton's party
did very well in those midterm elections
how do you see the economy playing in
this year's midterms
i think it's pretty obvious the
republicans can't run on it that's why
the president has to resort to fear and
loathing and make it fright night
halloween early with
i'm sending troops to the border oh
there's a caravan approaching
gangsters ms-13 terrorists
uh our diseases are approaching the
border and i'm sending the troops to
stop what kind of madness is this
greg was right there's a lot of things
that are being said that just aren't
true but
i said both sides juan i was being fair
yeah but i'm not being fair
because there's no analogous action by
the democrats what you have is
president trump wait a second of course
there's going to be a civil war
and he's hitler and he's going to lock
up basically i don't think
democrats are saying a civil war i get
the emails from pelosi
we're taking the social security i think
people are upset about
trump i mean democrats are always
talking about health care is the chief
issue running out and saying oh everyone
everyone's health care is going to be
taken away
isn't it true that republicans promised
that once they took over they would
repeal and replace that's not a scare
tactic
that's what republi and republicans
haven't done anything and only belatedly
now is the president saying
oh if you have pre-existing conditions
i'd consider he's
late to the game that's why he's
demonstrating
the game are you kidding one oh go right
ahead economy consumer confidence
we were talking about healthcare yeah
but you know what but with healthcare he
got rid of the
the individual mandate come on yes
that's why democrats are running ads and
while they're having success by saying
to americans
right now the health care system is in
jeopardy under trump so when they when
they use fear tactics
uh they're telling the truth what fear
when anybody else well social security
for one also talking about how evil
trump is how racist and insane he is
that's for your tactic it's not a fair
type there you go
when the truth is told you call it a
fair tactic on the left
trump makes up just pointing out
why is it crazy to be talking about
securing the border i mean that that
immigration immigration is everybody
talks about this jessie and i've been
over this a thousand times jesse likes
to say to me
remember when obama remember when other
people put in
additional security at the border i'm
awful and the reason the economy is the
caravan
has nothing to do with border security
let's move on hollywood he's doing
whatever it can to get out the vote
oprah
is hitting the campaign trail tomorrow
in georgia to sum for democratic
gubernatorial candidate
stacey abrams taylor swift posted that
she's voted for democrat phil bredesen
in the tennessee senate race
and is urging fans to not sit this one
out
so greg now celebrities getting involved
oprah you know i mean that's
the star oprah is different than the
alyssa milanos and the will
ferrell yeah and she and and you could
you know you trust what you have to say
i do believe though that the negative
impact of a moralizing celebrity of
limited intellect i'm not talking about
oprah
cancels the positive impact of their
famous face
so when you have somebody who is kind of
a newbie generally
when somebody gets into politics as a
celebrity they're stunted
it's like their politics is back where
they were when they decided to chase
fame so their politics are that of like
a 17 year old
yeah because yeah because for 10 years
10 years they've been all about
themselves
so finally they feel guilty about this
and then they go i'm going to become
politically aware but they're back at
where they were when they stopped
reading yeah but it's even worse than
that greg it's not like just 10 years
it's the fact that what did they do for
a living they don't think
they memorize the lines that other
people write well we kind of do that too
[Laughter]
no no i i everybody has everybody has a
right to an opinion but we have to be
able to analyze and say
where are they in the road to life and
the load how do they know
what is their experience what is it
based on i'm famous therefore you know
believe me and everybody in my ilk
writes his own lines because he's got
piles of notes
i didn't even i didn't even get to my
notes about this analysis because a
couple weeks ago you guys told me kanye
west was
oh he's great oh he's so smart he's a
businessman talk about
halloween
that has nothing to do with his stance
on trump you know what it's about back
when he was 17 and knew nothing
how about donald trump he's a celebrity
what people were defending were the
right of kanye west to have an
opinion yeah you were attacking him for
other reasons
you were attacking because he wasn't
using profanity the bottom line is
celebrities and republicans love them
celebrities aren't going to whether or
not i will say this i will say no one on
this side
called oprah or any of these other
taylor swift people mentally ill
no but in our criticism
kanye west suffered some of the most
horrible rhetoric
i've ever seen uttered about anyone on
television besides me
yes and he didn't deserve it okay and
that came from
your side yeah the birth the guy has
bipolar disorder by his own admission oh
that's mean
oh yes you have another disorder it's
called trump derangement